here with more florida senator marco
rubio senator
they're not only joe biden's policies
and not only aiding and embedding the
law breaking and enforcing the law but
they're also involved in human
trafficking because they're literally
transporting illegal immigrants into
every state around the country and then
just leaving them there and then it
becomes the responsibility of the state
to provide food water shelter medical
treatment health care and education and
most states can't afford it senator
yeah that's right look i think that
what's happening here but that's the tip
of the ice script by the way the stuff
that you're seeing now is the tip of the
iceberg as an example in florida you
know there's this pelosi puppet this
congresswoman val demings that chuck
schumer hand-picked to run against me
and she's in favor of like open
completely open borders of allowing
illegal immigrants to vote of not
deporting people even of their gang
members she's raised 30 something
million dollars for her campaign as a
result of of these stances this is i
think the speaker game which was on just
a moment ago and he talked about how
about this is how about values this is
about principles and they're wacky these
are radical ideas and what you're seeing
the images you're seeing are just the
tip of the iceberg of what of the kind
of agenda these people want to follow no
country in the world would allow the
lawlessness that we have with our
immigration system none
you know we just talked with newt
gingrich about the border disaster the
afghan withdraw afghanistan withdrawal
disaster the lack of urgency in ukraine
the economy 40-year high inflation a
wholesale price is a new record 40-year
record of inflation
energy now double what it was under
donald trump when joe biden inherited
energy independence
crime out of control by defund dismantle
the police and joe biden even ran out of
cover tests
around christmas going into the third
year of a pandemic i don't know how you
can do any worse than that
you really can and i think if you look
at every major issue in front of this
country everything is worse than it was
when joe biden took over everything is
worse than it was and frankly that's why
i need people's help i'm asking them to
go to marco rubio.com because i'm being
outraged because this movement from the
left
they know they can't win the election on
these issues they're they're what
they're trying to do is raise you know
tens of millions of dollars to destroy
people lie to them obviously they'll
have a lot of help from the mainstream
media so i need people's help to fight
back against this because
they don't want to hear that story they
don't want people hearing the reality
that on every issue immigration the
economy our national security our
standing in the world we are
substantially worse off today than we
were in january of last year when joe
biden took over on everything
your election is is critical this this
is a bellwether election year because
it's florida for the senate i'm talking
about specifically it's georgia it's
north and south carolina it's new
hampshire it's pennsylvania it's
missouri ohio it is wisconsin it is
nevada it is arizona it doesn't get any
more bellwether and it's alaska
hopefully kelly chewbacca can win up
there it doesn't get any more bellwether
senator your election is critical
one i think florida has a special place
in their heart it's been the place
that's embarrassed them because of the
state policies with governor desantis
our state legislature and so i think it
has a special place in their heart they
really really really want to win these
races in florida look i i'm just asking
everyone to go to marco rubio.com
because i need your help but you're
right it's a beltweather state and i
think because florida has embarrassed
the federal government has embarrassed
the performance of of blue states and
and blue cities across this country
they're desperate to win some races here
in florida and they're pouring a lot of
money into it
all right senator marco rubio thank you
as always for being with us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else